-Our first guest tonight
is a congressman
from Queens, New York,
who's involved in a lot of
controversy right now.
Here to set the record straight,
please welcome
Congressman George Santos.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Mr. Santos,
welcome to the show.
-Oh, hi, James.
Thanks for fitting me in.
Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just in town to pick up
my Nobel Peace Prize.
-Oh. Congratulations.
-Yeah, perform a couple nights
at Madison Square Garden, mm.
-I didn't know
you were playing MSG.
-Yes, yes.
I'll be singing
all my hit songs --
"Piano Man,"
"Hey Jude,"
"Happy Birthday."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm glad you're here,
Congressman,
because I have some questions.
A lot of people
have called you out
for lying about details
in your life.
What do you have to say to that?
-Well, you know,
I don't consider
the things I've said to be lies.
They're what my
great-grandfather,
Winston Churchill...
[ Laughter ]
He would call them
embellishments.
Embellishments, you know.
I embellish.
And on my hot dog, I put relish.
Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
I relish the embellish, Jimmy.
-Now, you --
[ Laughter ]
You said on your résumé that
you worked for Goldman Sachs,
and that is just not true.
-No, alright.
Fine, alright.
That, no -- That is...
The truth is I did not work
for Goldman Sachs.
-Hm.
-I AM Goldman Sachs.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I founded the company
many years ago.
But I changed my name
to George Santos
because who wants
the last name Sachs?
It stinks!
[ Laughter ]
-What about your education?
What about your education?
Where did you actually go
to school?
-Well, I'll be honest with you,
Jimmy.
I went to high school
in Euphoria, you see.
[ Laughter ]
But they kicked me out after
I broke up with Sydney Sweeney.
-You also lied
about being Jewish.
-No, no, no, no, no.
I never said I was Jewish.
I said I was Jew-ish.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
No, I did.
It's what I said.
No, the truth is,
I'm a part-time Jew.
[ Laughter ]
I am. Yes.
In my spare time, I'm
the prime minister of Israel.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm not only Jew-ish --
I'm Ir-ish, I'm Scott-ish,
and I'm half-fish.
[ Laughter ]
Delish!
-Now, you...
[ Laughter ]
You got some big
responsibilities now, okay?
You've been added
to the House Committee
on Science, Space,
and Technology.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you know much about that?
-Yes, yes, I've always been
involved in science.
You know, not to brag,
but it was my idea to have
gravity, you know?
[ Laughter ]
No, listen, before I showed up,
if you dropped something,
it would just float up
into the air.
Watch this.
You're welcome!
-Alright, well...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
You're also being investigated
by the House Ethics Committee.
Are you worried?
-Well, why would I be?
I have nothing to hide.
My name is George Santos.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm seven feet tall.
I invented baseball.
And "The Avengers" is based
on my friend group.
[ Laughter ]
-Before you go, Congressman,
there are millions of people
watching right now --
is there anything you want
to say to them?
-Yes, there is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Regrets, I have none ♪
-Did you say you have none?
-♪ I have a son ♪
♪ He's Harry Styles ♪
♪ Got first place ♪
♪ New York marathon ♪
♪ I even ran three extra miles ♪
♪ I've won every Super Bowl ♪
♪ Don't believe me? ♪
♪ Check my résumé ♪
♪ It's called the Holy Bible ♪
♪ I did it my way ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-George Santos, everybody!
-It's true, I tell you.
It's true!
All the lies. It's true!
-No, no, George --
-I'm Jimmy Fallon!
-No, you're not!
-This is my show!
-No, it's not your show.
George!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Get him out of here.